始め3階自室で待っています
僕の方からもよろしくお願います
こんにちははじめ社長ですお待たせしまし
た半周タグ電車絶対ヤバい話
ツイッターで沢山の gogo を
いただきますありがとうございましたなら
取れないも結構がっつりのってすごい
盛り上がっていたんですけどもあの電車
電車ですごい術ちゃって自分の見ず知らず
の人たちを全く違う誰かもしじゃない人と
健康の時間同じ場所で共有できるという
なかなか珍しい場所なんですよ2最強って
電車って不思議なことあったなんて高校
時代データ通学だったんで思い出して
みんなどういう体験したことあるんだろう
ってツイッターで走ってる電車で行った
ヤバい話で皆さんの電車話をちょっと募集
したんですけども本当に狂った黒いという
かもうこれは取り上げちゃいけないで
みたいなものからそんな微笑ましいことも
あったんだとかヤバイ話が幸せな形まで
ほんといろんなヤバい話をたくさん聞く
ことができましたありがとうございました
で今回実現可能なレベルあーこんなことを
あんたんだと長女さんから聞いた電車で
ってこんなヤバイ話待ったねっていうのを
ちょっとなんとか映像化させていただいた
ので統一の経験とあっていうかわかんない
んですけど五軒家の手が人に話せるレベル
動画にできるレベルでお揃いなって思うた
エピソードを動画化しましたので是非ご覧
ください
結構やばいです同3組
みんなが電車に乗ったことはあるだろうか
一の洲魔法
コストり覗き見している人
おじさんの肩に寄りかかっているおじさん
[音楽]
この中ならないずーっとおしゃべりして
いる作成
時間がなかったのか電車でお化粧している
女性
今日は
みんなが知らないような
電車であったヤバイ話を集めてみました
[音楽]
突然扉付近の床に座ってタロットカード前
で占い始めた人がいました
クラック次いだな
いいですよくれちゃいます
[音楽]
高校生の時
35差で痴女がでだとうわさになった次の
日のことでふーん
珊瑚砂一応以上に男でパンパンに前に行っ
た
友達の話なんだけど朝登校のために電車に
乗ってたら黒人に見える魅せられて
それもいいですね
これ
ナンバー転換ありますか
私も傷つきたくないのって書いてあります
[音楽]
そうですか
去っていったと思っ
[音楽]
コロナが流行り始めた2020年
ガスマスクつけてる人がいてビビった
ん
[音楽]
じゃあ
幸福はい作っていきます右にウイスキーの
瓶左手にコーラのペットボトルを持って
公開作って飲んでいる人がいた
[音楽]
アナウンスでしないでお困りの方を見つけ
ましたらお声がけくださいと流れるのは常
ですがある日車内でお困りの方につきまし
たらお困りください
て反応していました
ん
[音楽]
東京に住んでいた頃電車の握り棒でも9人
禁している人を見ました
寝ていて起きたら知らないオジサンの方で
寝ていたこと
[音楽]
ん
これはある日電車での出来事
目の前の7人掛けの座席の6人までが
メガネをかけた男性で埋まっていた
また人に
谷が深ければ
ほいでならねー
次の閑散としたいければ一人の命金の男性
が乗ってきたのだ
7人全員
名金になったのであった
[音楽]
ああ
ノブのを絶対ずあるマン
[音楽]
uh
ん
うーんムースカルダンいやお前をご覧張っ
た上毛
ナンパいいたちしたおじさんがドアに反射
してる自分と乾杯してしたないで no
あるのでたんです
10年前の俺じゃやってねおーおーわー
me
ae の乗ってんじゃないやっぱ
公開音が名前は風た
おじいさんが再来でいきなり腹筋をし始め
た
やばいんキャンプや
par
5 aeruler
yeah いえーい
[音楽]
えっ拙いやわー
電話しながら社内の減っては社内でもえっ
マジやばとデカイ声で飛んだり跳ねたりし
ながらで貝や鈴とを立てて車内を歩き回る
女性
ん
[音楽]
佐紀の水着でちょっとおしっこ漏れたから
お茶子作りしてごまかした
ますね往復どっか
いやもっ
ん
電車にてすごい王子物を持ったおばあさん
が降りようとして扉にその荷物が挟まっ
ちゃいました
男性2人が救助に向かって
[音楽]
wh女性の嫉妬
ていました反対語
扉が開いたら者を婆さんが俺を言うために
頭を下げました
ございます
避けた頭が挟まってました
ますblr
[音楽]
んっ
えっえっ